[Music]
evening everybody Welcome to three scary
games
I know it's been a while since the last
ones but
hope you haven't forgotten about me
I certainly have not forgotten about you
I could never forget about you
[Music]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to shiromi shirim the curse
of the Buddy
Yes you heard me correctly and yes
you're staring right into the brown eye
of the ghost of your nightmares that
which will be haunting you that which is
lurking right behind you all the time
because it is your behind
it's a butt ghost I don't know if this
is actually supposed to be scary or if
it's supposed to be like a goof game or
something like that the legend says that
only the most daring possessed the
courage to look into the eye of evil
a test of Courage that saw even the best
for
of these only one managed to find the
truth
but he was unaware that the ACT would
change his life forever
is it just me or is this really quiet my
girlfriend Sharon is being look soon
cranked the volume in her last message
she said she would go out to a louder
[Music]
quieter but she never came back louder
quieter quieter quieter quieter louder
louder quieter quieter louder louder
quieter quieter louder louder louder
quieter quieter louder quieter quieter
louder louder are you confused
louder
sign of her
thank you come on come on It's gotta be
around here somewhere
the note said something about
he said something about a test of
Courage
it doesn't look like anything
if she's been here for the last three
days
I've got a bad feeling about this
Sharon could you really be here
Moon
I have no idea
okay I gotta actually see if I can
change something about this why is this
sound oh that's a problem ah see at
least it wasn't your fault at all it was
me I'm sorry
all right now where were we we were in
the middle of uh trying to examine
objects this diary belongs to Sharon and
it talks about an altar and a test of
courage to Faith
further on is there a path that starts
from the entrance of this place that can
only truly lead to the altar mentioned
in the notes I didn't
games unfollow unfollow release the
horror game that treats the drama the
modern world in a whole new way
well I did I wouldn't know anything
about that because I'm busy playing this
game I'm not going to stop playing this
one and then just jump into the next one
okay so there's something about a test
of courage or something of that nature
and then I'm pretty sure that there's a
bug ghost
I'm almost 100 positive that there's a
ghost of the butt
ah this is Sharon's driver or a driving
license maybe this clue can help me find
her maybe
hops
probably not though
all right
well I have that now
hello
uh
candles in the middle of the woods are
never really a good idea what
okay those are my legs I thought it was
my
I feel like this should have been
important but it
there seems to be nothing here
okay
I'll go back the way I came then
man there's a huge difference between
runting and running and sprinting
what am I looking at a rock
okay
I feel like I should have looked at the
map a little closer because then that
might have told me the path I need to
take
oh never mind found it
okay
hello
Sharon
anybody seen share
well that can't be good
Grandma fell asleep and they just put a
tarp over her okay that's fine
all right what is this I can't whoa
you'll see him if you look Among Us
Among Us oh that's not the transcription
that's not the transcription at all I
knew it was coming for me I closed my
eyes and waited for the end I don't
think you did
I don't think that's what that says
oh my God
did that see seven of eight pages
oh no it's Slender ass oh my God I am
Among Us
oh
oh no
there's so much worse than I ever could
have imagined
just can't look Among Us
but it's so tempting it's so tempting it
throws me in
just the perfect being the perfect
hunter
that epitome of evolution oh my God it
is oh God it's Slenderman
is uh
is the butt man approaching from the
ominous humming that I hear in the
distance or his Edge is my own Insanity
slowly
slowly I have a bad feeling about this
God I didn't see this
I don't know why I didn't think of this
at all
this is Slenderman's woods and I'm being
pursued by a bud ghost
God damn it
God damn it I was blind to the truth
I think
well if I don't beat this one I'm not
gonna be too upset because I've still
never beaten the original Slenderman I
don't know why God I gotta do that
sometime I just want to do a live stream
where all I do is play and beat the
original
Slenderman
it's like
can I even consider myself a YouTuber if
I haven't done that
uh oh hello what are you hi
okay
building anybody seen a note
anybody seen another page
oh no
oh my God
oh no wait
no
until it what Untold follows
oh my God oh
God no no no no
oh I'm not dead I thought I would be
dead instantly well I'm about to be
oh my God
this is all right okay
um wow
oh my God hey wait a minute hey good
buddy why don't you hold on a little bit
I have only two pages in you can't be
that merciless give me a chance man
give me a chance
okay I'm getting a little bit of
distance
is that you breathing or is that me
breathing
okay I see trucks and train cars and oh
I got away okay that's lovely thank you
thank you but I haven't really been able
to pay attention to see if I got any
more pages I probably passed them by
you know if I remember my mission right
I'm actually here to find Sharon
but I seem to be sidetracked by this
collection Quest
okay well that was useless what was the
point of that
it's not even a page or maybe there was
a page and I didn't see it I don't know
if they're like landmarks anywhere
hello
breathe
like that also I think I cranked the
graphics Fidelity a bit too high and my
two 40 90s can't handle this game it's
just too much oh it's too good
okay what is how did I get back here
what that doesn't make any sense how was
I there what is this hello
candles here is that good is this
important this feels important okay
ah yes
oh my
God no I'm trying to get the just there
we go okay
uh what is this I saw something tonight
it was a Yokai shirimay as the locals
call it but it has an i instead of a
butt
and it has no face I don't
what it has an eye instead of a butt it
is
it has a butt instead of an everything
it has a butt instead of a I don't know
I stumbled upon an altar wait a minute I
didn't know that I could be gotten hello
where are you
oh you know what I'm just gonna accept
my fate I I deserve this no I don't
deserve this
oh I don't deserve this oh I don't just
okay
[Music]
all right
as much as I would like to 100 this and
take the next two hours to perfect my
strategy and get the map all together
and then run away from the blood eye I
think I'm gonna just let this one go I
just can't face the horror that is the
double cheek of evil
um the brown eye of Injustice is staring
hard into my soul and I just I can't
afford to stare back so I'll leave this
one to you
to avenge my death I am the one writing
you a note from the Beyond
I stared into the darkness and the
Darkness stared back
[Music]
I could make more puns I guess I'm just
gonna leave this one here good game
though
for something that
is the curse of the bud eye and I'm sure
this has a long storied history that
actually is very relevant and important
uh but I'm Gonna Leave This one here
maybe I'll beat it someday thank you
moving on
welcome to
the pizza that's a pizza or is it
probably
of you I am so excited for the party
today I need to prepare everything
I should first order a pizza there
should be a flyer with the number
somewhere in the house
call Pizza butt
well that's
pizza but
hmm
Pizza butt
eight three four seven one one guy
hello
greetings man this conversation is not
going well I would like to order four
large
[Music]
pineapple pizzas please
very well your order will arrive shortly
we hope you will
enjoy it well that's weird I didn't tell
you my address or anything all right now
I need to prepare some snacks and a
movie
I should set everything up in the living
room
I like having friends social
interactions are Grand I hope my patrons
will enjoy my art
I made it myself
gather three snacks and a movie
hope people like my asymmetrical mirror
set up no
I keep my chips in the fridge
Wham
pizza or friends could could that be one
of the guests I don't know their names I
invited strangers
hello
greetings
well hopefully hopefully people can find
my house
nothing strange about that
whatever the hell this is I bet it's
tasty I bought it at the human food
store
greetings you have chosen wrong
foreign
nothing strange about
this
oh it's not a mirror it's a window
well hope I don't make any more wrong
choices
mate
guests love meat
who doesn't
that's strange I should check the
breaker it's located outside in the back
because of course it is
well I don't like this
don't mind me
I'll close my door cause that's the
smart thing to do
hi
um oh I'm walking
oh
us
yes strange
not gonna comment on that
because of the two of us
I'm the weird one
hate
hate that
time to gather a movie
wherever the hell a movie would be
now where would a movie be
was that a second set of footprints or
was that just My Mind Playing Tricks on
Me movie
keep it by my bed for safe keeping
movie obtained
put it there
could that be one of the guests
I bet I bet I bet
oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Music]
well I don't know what I was expecting
I'm gonna guess that was one of the
guests just so excited and barreled
right through me and into the living
room so we could watch that movie
together and enjoy the meat and pizza
great game got me
very creepy
moving on
last night
last night manual
well play
June 12 2008.
this is my first day of work at this
restaurant
okay
to get to the place of work
how
I thought that was meat
that's a bush interesting
air news residents of the city are
worried about the fate of the missing
employee of the
Haunted Hamburger today residents of our
city were stunned by the news that a
young man who was an employee of a
well-known restaurant was missing
Michael Brown 22 left home last night to
go to work but did not returned home by
morning police have already opened an
investigation and urging anyone with
information about Michael to contact
them an extensive search is underway
throughout the city as well as in
neighboring communities police are also
appealing to anybody who may have seen
something suspicious or witnessed
anything unusual to contact them
glad my name's not Michael whatever that
was
hey look The Haunted Hamburger what a
suspicious place to work
also what's wrong with my eyeballs
peekaboo
I don't like that I can open that
I don't like that that can be opened in
general
because that suggests that um
maybe someone else could open it
what in the hell
don't do that
whatever you are and whoever you are
[Music]
great I'm so glad that that exists is
that for people
who want to eat here
go clear the workplace of Deborah's and
put it in order
all right I'll do just that fine is this
Deborah's
oh it is Deborah okay
why is there so much debris
[Music]
interesting
why is this here
instructions for making the perfect
burger to cook the burger you'll need a
cooktop build plate and TV screen with
the desired recipe start by frying the
meat and on the hob waiting for it to
cook then gather follow the recipe on
the TV screen and gather all the
necessary ingredients on the build panel
that's it your Burger's ready okey dokey
fine
there's mask required meat all right
uh
[Music]
okay generally seems to be in order
um
oh hi
am I supposed to clean this up too
okay
hi
who in the hell
do you think you are
put in an order is there more Deborah's
that I'm not seeing
[Music]
that's nice
roast meat cheeseburger buns okay you
got it
roast meat
[Music]
burger buns
and cheese
[Music]
oh good
not 100 sure what I'm supposed to be
doing about that are we open or what
they're the workplace of debris I still
need to clear the works oh is this the
last one
no no
[Music]
Oh I thought that was someone jingling
some keys and trying to get in
oh turn on exterior assignment oh
okay so it was just that one thing
wasn't quite in the trash can I think
that was what the concern was
serve all customers by processing and
fulfilling their orders you got it
hello
hoping for business
I'll make you a delicious Burger
cook up another one
oh hello
howdy welcome to haunted whatever hi
what'd you want
okay Burger green donut purple donut
sure
what what my what Berg what it vanished
what
I hope that didn't just soft lock me
hold on
I had a burger clip through the for
forever Zone do I put him here
green donut
yeah I hear you
hold on
no here
but uh
Todd oh
here you go
you're welcome
okay well that one worked fine
[Music]
I don't know where the other one went it
kind of disappeared into Oblivion
um and I don't see any more Burgers so
uh that might be a problem
hello
Burger milk
[Music]
it's weird
pink donut you got it
there you go
I don't have any more Burgers it
literally evaporated into nothingness
make a trip to the warehouse for me
warehouse warehouse
Warehouse
I should close this
that would be the smart thing to do
is this the warehouse
oh good great
yeah it's just our meat no
oh okay
I have meat
I have meat I got one meal
[Music]
you were last seeing the day you
disappeared
I sure was
why are you still here
[Music]
you know I I I I I don't know I I have
no idea why am I still here
you got that right all right so that was
last night you remember what happened
last night because I sure don't that was
the day I disappeared
[Music]
thank you for joining me for yet another
three scary games always good to play
some scary games never good to end the
episode and then you're only haunted by
your dreams and the Shadows but don't
worry
I'll be there
in the Darkness
ready
I'm waiting
[Music]
foreign